when when this is happening when this is
getting like
when when
when he leaves in the morning and you
you start thinking like where is he
is there any part of your brain that's
thinking
he could kill himself
no
well i take that back
i did ask
chad's dad
i was trying to get into the safe
um
so i guess i guess there was a part of
me that did but
this he this was a little farther on in
the morning so when i first couldn't
find him i just couldn't find him but
then after a while
i think it might have been his dad that
said have you checked the safe
and so it took me a minute to try to
remember the combo
and i got in there and
to my knowledge all the guns were there
but apparently they weren't
i guess the reason i'm asking you that
is because
i don't know various conversations in my
i've had in my life with various people
at various times
and the conversation is something like
you know
you know that little exploration of
hey
i'm worried about him
and then there'll be some kind of an
explanation like
what do you mean well i'm just worried
like
he might kill himself
and then the conversation is
he would never do that
right so that idea of
we think we know we think we know what
someone's going through we think we know
what's going on in their heads
and
i think that
we don't know we don't always know and
you know like um
he disappears you know like what that's
what i was just thinking like what was
that in your head of like hey you know
what he's
you know he probably is going to see his
parents or he's you know going to go
freaking surfing or whatever he's going
to do
but this crazy idea
that
he might go kill himself
it seems so
unbelievable
you know um for someone that's like hey
he's been through whatever 10
deployments he's done all this he's done
this he's done that we got kids we got a
house we got all these things going on
all these good things going on in our
lives that's not a that's not gonna
happen
and it seems like oftentimes
people are caught off guard by it
people are caught off guard and i know
you mentioned a couple of friends where
there was
real signs of you know hey
not things aren't going good for the
individual but uh but a lot of times i
hear it's like
you know there's been some suicides in
the seal community where there was
no indication at all
at all of any kind
and and
it seems like we're conditioned to sort
of not even think that it's a feasible
thing
i
guilt
you know i i was just as bad as
as
the military makes
the guys out to be because
as i said in his funeral
to me
chad was unbreakable
i mean
to me
he had done all these really
amazing things in his life
he
he's
you know he everything he did he did
well everything he did and
seal you know
great
ridiculous high gpa when he's going to
night school and he has a wife and a
baby and
really good in sniper school and
went and got his project manager
license certification all that in the
business world and
whatever fill in the blank
climbing mountains
qualifying for the crossfit games like
insert whatever
he just was so unbreakable to me
and and i guess
that's
part of my
what i want people to recognize with
your person is that
they are their navy seals but at the end
of the day you're just dudes
you know your dudes and
humans and
with a heart and a conscience and
dads and husbands and brothers and sons
and
not unbreakable